yeah so
i mean i
had some questions i um
i asked
that we need to have more information
before
this is because i'm not sure that this
is the proper way to do it and um i
think that dhhs needs to have some
feedback um
or to us about the normal process of
this
if it's appropriate because i i believe
that they probably set this rate
themselves
and um through rules
and um
you know we can have discussion about
whether or not this is
appropriate and needs to be amended but
there's um
uh it should go through that rules
creating process is my first thought
about it and without additional
information i i think that that
right and i and i agree while the bill
is very well intended first of all this
is not a budget year so
dcyf would have to pull this money out
of their existing budget for what the
state has to cover
and i think it amounts to 40 cents
so
i
right
good good intention but
i think there's a different procedure
that this needs to go through
my thoughts exactly yeah i think it
should be brought back during a budget
year it's it's
important enough to do that
go ahead josh i'm not sure that it
should be brought back i think it may
just be going through the wrong process
if they if we reached out to dhhs and
said hey what's going on
um
is this appropriate they may have
information that yes this is appropriate
and you know you know based on other
states or how like you know more
information than we got at the hearing
and and say no we're we we're not um
uh supporting a change or an increase or
we are supporting a change and it's not
happening because x y and z and maybe we
can help in those impediments but
um i'm not sure that this like kind of a
reach around
of their
control like into their spaces
without their input is is the best
best avenue right
is there any further discussion
all right
seeing none i'll have the clerk call the
roll
ready representative
yes representative desimone votes yes
representative keller
yes representative your color votes yes
representative nelson
yes
representative smith
representative long
yes representative
nottingham yes representative grossman
representative levesque
representative
yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk votes
yes representative alice uh once
not here absent and
madam
voters 11 to 0.
without objection we can place this on
consent
15 15.
sorry
do i have a motion for 15 15.
okay so the motion is ought to pass and
the bill is open to further amendment
i would like to motion to adopt
uh amendment zero three one nine h and
thank you
you can speak to your amendment thank
you um so this amendment is
um
kind of uh one of the things that was
brought up at the hearing
um or
in the language of the bill um it said
that
in certain situations the gal can kind
of recommend
what they think should happen to the
judge
and that's really not the role of the
gal the gal is a fact-finding
arm of the
judge and not
their advisor
and so
um this
this uh the
amendment will replace the
the um existing language and will
of the bill and we'll just amend that
the report from the gal shall include
only factual information and shall not
propose any recommendations
thank you
because if you recall that was a lot of
the complaints that we heard was that
there were just a lot of recommendations
being made and i will tell you a few
years ago representative long and i were
on a study committee and it was my
understanding that
we had removed
the recommendations
part already and then to my surprise i
looked it up and apparently didn't
follow the bill enough to see that it
included three exceptions
so what the amendment does is just
removes those three exceptions it's not
getting rid of gals
but hopefully this will create a little
less conflict
and
okay so
we will speak
i mean we will
vote on adopting amendment
20220319h
on the amendment representative uh
dismal yes
representative your color yes
representative nelson yes
representative belanger is not here
representative
klett yes
i thank you
representative bean yes representative
smith
yes representative long yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative grossman is not here
representative levesque not here yes she
is she's here
wonderful
and your vote representative yes
representative tollerski yes
representative petrino the clerk votes
yes representative altila here not here
and madam chair rice
yes
so
the motion would now be
to pass as amended is the motion second
and by
yes representative long
okay
so when the clerk's ready we'll have him
call the roll on ought to pass as
amended
[Laughter]
i got it wrong i
okay
octopass has amended it
representative desimone
yes
representative yo keller yes
representative nelson yes representative
belanger not here representative
platt yes
representative bean
representative smith
yes representative long yes
representative notting wong
yes representative grossman not here
representative levesque yes
representative tolusky yes
representative petrino the clerk yes
representative altsula is not here
madam chair rice yes okay the motion
passes
11 12 12 to nothing
without objection we'll put that on
consent
okay
consent so that is okay up next um
so okay we'll go back to top 15 31.
give me one second and i'll tell you
modifies the oversight commission on
children's services so um
can you make who's making that motion
about that i'm going to move out to pass
please second second
i have an amendment
that i'll pass out and it has senator
carson's name on it
but i have one in ols i i mean i had
them put it in my name so if we adopt it
it'll come out
um like that but so what this does
it repeals the entire bill the it
replaces the entire bill
and it just repeals
the commission to study grand families
and the commission to review child abuse
fatalities and i will tell you why that
is
because we are going to combine
those two commissions
into the oversight commission on
children's services
this was senator whitley
we had a meeting on friday and this is
um
what she requested that we do and she is
the prime sponsor
and then when it gets to the senate and
we're done hearing from the members as
to which roles
will be played senator carson is going
to
amend it to add those
roles the the further members that are
needed so to speak for pulling from both
of those commissions so that it's all
under one and we don't have
people trying to be in three places at
once
we don't have
the director ribsum trying to run
everywhere and so this is this is one
thing that and i'll be honest when i
co-sponsored it it was my intent that
that's what this bill would do
it's what i thought it was going to do
but when it came before us it was very
confusing and stuff so in talking with
senator whitley senator carson um
who else was there
now i can't remember but this is what we
came up
with okay so do you have a question
representative ocala
just a comment oh sure
um
i i was talking with um
the
child advocate after that hearing and it
did seem that there was a lot of
duplication that she was having to go
and say the same things to a bunch of
different commissions and so i think
that um this is a good idea to try and
combine some of those so that it will
take some load off of her in
in not
getting less information out just
getting it more directly and not having
to duplicate
so exactly thanks exactly
is there any other
um
questions or comments
discussion
okay
so when the clerk's ready i'll i'll have
him call the roll for amendment
let me make sure that's the right number
on this hold on they may have changed
well it's in it's in senator carson's
name so we can't
so it's 0 5 9 7 h
oh really yeah because it can't be it
can't be in senator carson's name it's a
technically a committee amendment 0.
9 7 8.
sorry about that yes
content's exactly the same
i just went down there and said i need
okay
all right thank you sorry about that
confusion
all right are we ready to vote on the
amendment yes
okay voting on the amendment
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes representative
nelson yes representative belanger
representative plett yes representative
bean
representative smith yes representative
long yes representative notting wong
yes
representative levesque
yes i apologize representative tolerski
yes
representative petrino that's me
yes representative altula is absent
representative grossman just entered yes
okay
and madame chair rice yes okay that is
everyone
okay
did you email
ols and tell them that we adopted that
[Music]
amendment and to ask them to send it for
so we have to send it we have to email
them once it's approved
and then you can ask them to send it to
house committee services is that correct
christina
oh okay that'd be great all right never
mind she's gonna do it awesome i just
okay is there a second on that on uh
okay
all right uh voting on ought to amend it
uh ought to pass as amended
representative dissimo yes
representative yokela
yes representative nelson yes
representative
belanger yes representative plett yes
representative bean
representative smith yes representative
long yes representative nutting wong
yes representative grossman
yes representative levesque
yes representative toloreski yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk is voting yes
representative altsula
okay
and madam chair rice
yes okay that is unanimous so without
objection
okay
so up next we'll do hb 1265.
do i have a motion
12.65
1265 is relative to a judge's discretion
to set aside rules and family court
proceedings
yep code
cody did it oh
but yes
then um to pass
is my uh motion and then
we got that yesterday seconds or no no
no way i wanted to wait okay
second it says cody on my on my list
oh it does say jody i'm sorry joe second
second yes second
pass it out
all right yeah so we can pass up
so the the motion is ought to pass
and um
i'm going to recognize representative
belanger
to
introduce an amendment
which is coming around
uh thank you madam chair um so
basically when we heard testimony from
from many of these people
uh
one of the things that we wanted to
amend this to was to require a database
as to the reason why
the family court rules were being waived
what it does is
essentially if a judge waves a court
rule
they have to explain why
there is a database and requires the
judicial branch to provide that database
to the chair of this committee the chair
of senate judiciary and
the senate president and the speaker of
and uh
hopefully we can kind of have an idea of
where this goes and i hope that we can
support this amendment
thank you
um i would just like to say when when
discussing this amendment that
you know we get quarterly reports from
um director ribsum
um we get quarterly reports from the
office of the child advocate so i don't
think it's unreasonable
to request a quarter quarterly report so
we can see if there's trends somewhere
if there are any changes that maybe we
need to make
and we can't do that without the
information so i think this will give us
good information
is there any further discussion
definitely good representative long they
can take it madam chair so
currently we don't receive any data
because they're not keeping the data so
this amendment requires them to keep the
data and report to us quarterly
yes right okay great thank you
okay
any further questions
okay so the motion oh representative
alt-shiller
i'm looking at this legislation and it
says it takes effect
60 days after passage
which i don't
i don't know that uh
i'm just saying that i don't know that
anyone can put a can formulate
the infrastructure for a database
to be in operation within 60 days is
that it seems that seems like for
something that doesn't exist we're not
asking to
reform a database that exists we're
asking them to come up with an entirely
new system which i don't disagree we
should i
i am in favor of the
nature of this bill and of all the
things
and i'm worried about the 60 days of
passage not being an adequate amount of
time to build what we really need
okay so let me ask richard head who
happens to be sitting in the audience
if we have a
okay
okay representative belanger
uh so uh thank you madam chair and thank
you for uh mr head for being here today
i i think uh representative all schiller
brings up a good point and just kind of
going through this process
i was not aware of the court procedure
with that being said i have
no problem trying to get that figured
out
if you just email them and ask them to
make this amendment but fix that the
change the effective date to your
amendment to january 1 2023 they can do
that
and then we can vote on it and they'll
be quick they're usually quick about it
so is everyone comfortable with voting
on the amendment
without having the new one here
oh wait well it'll need it'll be a new
number so we have to wait yeah okay so
i'll recess
this executive hearing
and we'll come back to it when we have
the
the amen the changes to the amendment
great
okay
so
what's the madam chair yes yep
i know we just recessed that's just kind
of whether a question about this sure um
and maybe it's just because i'm i'm just
reading it now representative bellinger
so it's
where what where is that like who would
you 24 to 27 thank you 24.
and of course should we put something in
i mean we're just really looking for
names in the
reasons we don't i mean not names but
the rule that was waived why
yeah number line 13 it says the number
the the rule wave by number the title
the party in whose favor the rule was
raised so we wouldn't want a name just
just the defendant versus the right the
um
plaintiff right
yeah representative
so uh thank you madam chair so i'm
wondering it's public information
anyways isn't that the name yeah of the
of the parties of the of the case yeah
it is that's right public information so
it wouldn't matter oh it's not no it's
not well
no mr head's shaking his head yeah no
not all i've got because there are some
that they don't put it out there
especially in domestic violence cases
correct
i mean
i mean do we have to specifically say
plaintiff versus defendant
or
okay
but do we have to clarify that in the
amendment do you think
i'm concerned that uh survivors of
domestic violence and um i agree family
court that has um trafficking involved
with it um particularly familial
trafficking that this information which
is under seal and enclosed courtrooms
will now be
there's a long list of people who would
have access to that and it's
i don't think i don't believe there
should be any names no case numbers
we just want to know
the rule
why it was waived
and
whether it was the petitioner or the
um what's the other one
respondent thank you
it's been a long time okay so can that
go into the amendment that it clarifies
as petitioner and respondent
so just instead of the party whose
favorite was world like um and whether
it was the defendant or respondent who
i'm happy to submit the amendment but i
was trying to email
the other minute and wasn't paying
attention fully so if somebody could
draft me language i'd be happy to send
it we're just going to change line 13
and
at the end and the plaintiff or
defendant whose favor the rule was
waived
and whether it was the defendant or a
plaintiff got it okay thank you right
now thank you representative belanger no
problem thank you my question if i made
man yes
uh thank you madam chair the the um
i mean is there an advantage knowing
whether it's the pointer for the
defendant
is is
is that information gonna be helpful to
us you know uh you do think it is
so because we're not gonna know if it's
male or female we're not there's not
gonna be any identifying factors other
than
they were the plaintiff
or the respondent i mean okay i have
representative blanchard thank you
veterinarian so um to uh representative
long's point i i i see kind of where
you're
iffy on the the fact but i think what's
important if we're providing if the
judicial branch is providing
a report on
the court rules we want to know
you know was that court rule in favor of
person a or was it in favor of person b
and i think it's important to know that
information so that if there is a trend
we can you know the chair can
ask those questions and go okay what's
going on here
um i think it's important piece
representative yokela i think in
individual in
um the idea is
in
a specific case or a specific rule it's
not that valuable but when you aggregate
it
over a number of cases it should be
about 50 50
that it's going one way versus another
if it was 75 percent the defendants then
that would be
really weird um that always get the
rules waived and so um just as a
statistical thing to make sure that
nothing um
is
uh
you know
untoward i guess okay representative all
chiller thank you madam chair um
if i recall from the notes i took during
the the testimony um and some of the
questions that were coming here out of
the committee
uh the the issue was um
why why rules were being waived
which rules were being waived and for
what reason those rules were being
waived
we
and perhaps this is my interpretation
but
we heard from a lot of um
plaintiffs
complaints about
court rules being waived
and um
i don't think that i personally i
thought that our focus and the reason we
wanted to do this was to find out if
there's an abundance of that we would be
able to see like the court heard x
number of cases
of those x number of cases rules were
waived in this percentage of them and of
those rules
this particular rule seems to be one
that gets waved a lot and that was the
information we were looking for yeah not
i'm not necessarily trying to
i didn't
i didn't hear
that we were looking for
um a scale of
which side was being
um was being favored or not favored
because
well everyone all of those courses are
in family court they're all unique
however the the rules that are being
waived
and then create a further uniqueness and
so what that's what i thought that's
what we were looking for is what rules
seem to always be on the table for
change
okay
representative long thank you uh also on
line 17 it says um the case by name and
number so that oh yeah
shouldn't that be omitted yeah we can't
have the case by name and number
i'll have it stricken yeah
i'm wondering
if
a case can be identified by
um
if
by the
you know by saying whether it was the uh
responder or
you know identifying that i think that
with all the um cases they hear area i
think somebody would have to be really
really good
you know what i mean representative
yokela yes um i think that if the if the
case was um heard in open court then um
obviously the anyone that was there or
would be able to know
firsthand what it was if it wasn't an
open court then there's no way that the
people not there are going to be able to
track one to one
you know and so um also
um
one of the things that was brought up in
those hearings was um
a concern that there was repetitive
motions being made
by a single party
i'm not sure if this
would
would help with that
but we may be able to see if multiple
um uh
uh examples
were waived for a single
case that would be
um unusual
and and something that we might want to
look into further
as far as
versus you know they're scattered one
rule you know doesn't apply versus one
case that has you know 15 rules that god
got waived and
and the person obviously the defendant
or
the person the responding is
um
or
it's hard for them to know what what to
expect if all the rules are just getting
thrown out right and so that's that's
something that i would be interested in
also so thank you
okay
but i do agree that we do need to remove
um
the case by name and number
in which the rule was waived
man i'm sure
yes i'm currently writing that email now
hey before i
yeah let's hold off one second to make
sure there's nothing else we need to
oh
yes
um
i saw that and i'm gonna fix it anyway
okay thank you representative yokela so
as as i was trying to allude to in my
last name and um i don't really care
about the case number but i would like
some way to identify that you know it's
all regarding the same case versus you
know all spread out between different
cases
i just don't know how it could be that
it could be
i mean just any
you could say like you know
case one we did blah blah blah case two
we wave this rule case three we waived
seventeen rules case four so you it
doesn't really matter which then is that
you want
for each case
i mean i want it to be able to be tied
back yeah to so that
i that we would be able to know if
there's
i just don't know how we do that without
identifying
the people because the case number
anyone can go and look up and we don't
want to leave
put anyone in jeopardy
you know what i mean
right i mean i know that my case and my
information was sealed in my
um
case because
the man tried to kill me
so and went to jail they didn't want him
to ever know where i was
you know so
i don't want to put anybody
in that situation because it's really
scary
so do you know what i mean go ahead
so as i was stating i don't think that
that
the specific case number
or is of value to this committee it's
it's knowing that
um
you just want each case anonymized way
of saying hey being anonymous
and all the rules that were waived for
case one say so to speak right all the
rules that were
so that we so that
um it so how do we put that in writing
in
here mister head do you have any
right
okay
representative simone
thank you madam chair i'm thinking that
if we were to use a particular date
and then case one two three four five
that would help i mean
however but he's got to look at it
through the database
right
okay
is he going to find
information or just go next okay that's
fine yeah so
i mean if i can yep um i don't think
that this is like
the
most important issue and i'm not sure
that it needs to be solved with this
amendment we we can you know talk with
mr head and and draft some some language
that works with them um in and and
propose that in the senate it's not
it doesn't need to be all solved today
right okay representative altschiller
thank you madam chair so um
the the issue that we're struggling with
right now is safety for um
the people who are involved in these
cases
and how do we keep them safe um and
and
also
gather that information and so instead
of asking the courts to
come up with another identification
system
with you know
passcodes and so on and so forth
would
would the committee be open to
um
in section
three
um
or i'm sorry in section four the
quarterly report you mean roman numeral
for roman numeral four thank you
roman numeral four that the quarterly
report
um
and also roman numeral three that
when we when
people outside of the court system have
access which is a lot of people
that those case numbers be redacted is
that
does that get us to where we want to go
do you see what she's saying
yes i see what she's saying um but
redacted just means like a black line
covering over it so that's not going to
give us case one click case two no it
would be every case the rules that were
waived under that case number would be
with it but the case number would
actually be redacted when it comes out
to the reports to the people so
yeah if that can be done and that yeah
you know we i think the well it can be
done
no i mean if if it is
not um overly burdensome for that
um
to be implemented by the
the um judicial branch i am not opposed
to
um a myriad of different ways that they
they could get this that us the
information so i think that it's best
if we kind of like table that idea of
by case
and i could reach out to
uh mr head and
um between now and in the senate we can
get some feedback on that to try and
address that specific issue but right
now if you didn't have any case numbers
in this bill that would be fine with
miata and then we can address that um
getting it grouped by a case
number in the senate when when the
judicial branch has had time to see what
best work is easiest for their i.t
you know department yeah representative
belanger
so are we changing this any further than
the two changes
that we've already addressed three
changes the well i've already sent that
email so i apologize okay
but yes
representative long yeah i think yep
yeah i'm fine with the three changes the
start date
the uh redacting the two
initial um the real wave binary and
oh no wait wait the rule waived by name
and title
is actually the name of the rule
no no no on line 18
the case by name and number and then the
party whose favor
part 17 num line 17 the case by name and
number those right that's actually we're
taking that right you're taking that out
and then 18 the party in whose favor the
rule was waived to put defendant or
right
and then the uh
the effective date let's see right okay
and
so do you do you see that representative
belanger what we're talking about
yes miss uh madam chair so i just was
before representative long um
jumped in and to clarify that um i have
rewritten it and i want to clarify how
it sounds before i send off this email
so on line 13
i said please allow for this to be
written um title the reason for which
the rule was waived
comma and who the waiver favored by
identifying if it was the plaintiff or
the defendant is that sufficient for
it is yeah
okay thank you and then
so the um
the wording that you just read um sorry
wasn't fast enough to write it down the
we're currently
saying
asking for who
um requested the waiver essentially
we're saying the defendant requested the
waiver it was granted
um
or the the plaintiff requested the
waiver and the way that that you phrased
it it sound like we are now
under that language would be collecting
who
was
who the plaintiff the other one
the person that was affected by the
waiver and not the person that requested
the waiver is that um can you re-read it
or
or answer to who is affected was it the
respondent or the
or was it the plaintiff or the defendant
that requested the waiver sure so the
way that i have written it says the
reason for which the rule was waived and
who the waiver favored by identifying if
it was the plaintiff or the defendant
so
representative long thank you
yeah there was testimony um
where the judge will wave it without
even a request
the judge will just say uh okay you had
10 days to get this in it's the 13th day
i'm waving at
and and the person didn't even request
it
right
so
who who who who it favored
yeah yeah i think who it favored is is
good enough
yeah i think who it favored is good
for defendant
what if the
the
judge believed that it favored both
parties
then he can say both okay who cares
right he can say
i'm sure yes
and then to fix representative alt
schiller's concerns regarding represent
lines 17-19 i have it written as referee
who waved the rule striking the case by
name and number in which the rule was
waived that has been stricken
and then continues the party
if the waiver was ruled in favor of the
plaintiff or the defendant the rule wave
by name and title and the cause for
which the rule was waived
is that sufficient yes
that sounded good yeah i will send them
very good thank you very much i'm sorry
one more
wait wait wait so sorry um
can i just read that back to you
starting on 17
referee who waved the rule comma
which rule was waived
no did you just strike that
yes
okay and then picks up with the rule
waived by name and title
no okay i'm sorry i missed a piece it
picks back up at
the party okay
the party in whose favor the rule was
waived rewritten as the party if the
waiver was ruled in favor of the
the party comma or the party if
you already stayed in the first change
right
so that's duplicate i'm just
i mean it is duplicated in multiple
locations on the bill but but if i'm i'm
just i'm thinking about like the
chronology of how
the where the chronology of how this
would happen
would be
the judge
who or referee who waved the rule that
would be first so the person who did it
second
which rule did they waive
third
what is the name and title of that rule
fourth
the cause for which the rule was waived
and then finally
who benefited from that ruling
that
yeah
do you have a suggestion as to how i
should rewrite that representative
i absolutely do
you want me to just type it out and send
it to you please
actually i'll just put it on a piece
paper
can i just say i love the way we are
working together like this it's
delightful this really brings me
so much happiness and makes me feel good
about being here today well it's still
early
[Laughter]
and i i do not look through life with
rose
i'm certain we won't agree on everything
but the best thing about this is we just
do it so respectfully with each other
and i really appreciate that because
there have been moments this morning
included i'm just like saying i'm done
so
you guys have all restored some of my
faith in this
so while we're waiting on that there's
no more discussion on that i'm going
there's more discussion
no i was just um
being that it's 9 50 it would be maybe
we could um
if we're if we're done with the
discussion we could take a break and and
have that language completely drafted
and then we could come back and maybe a
recess of like 20 minutes yes how about
we do that a recess of 20 minutes
and then we will be back here at 10
minutes past
10. i'm not going to be back here at 10
minutes past 10 why not
that's 20 minutes
20 minutes would be 10 minutes can we
can we do 10 o'clock madam chair no it
has to be 10 10 okay or or 10 15 i mean
give them time to write the the
amendment he has to do something
okay that's fine so 10 15 we'll be back
everyone okay
is that okay yes right before we leave
can can uh representative bollinger read
that out loud and make sure we're all
really
so all right so let's all right let's
just say if it's not let's come back at
10 15 if it's not ready we'll move on to
the next one
so we're back from recess
and we're going to pick up where we left
off we were waiting for an amendment to
oh my gosh what bill
yes
all right and he has it back and all the
changes have been made i think christina
just ran up to get us copies
that way we can all look over over it
and um
and then we can
hopefully
make a boat
happen
and hopefully representative yokela will
all right so we can all take a minute
and look through
but up top
it states
who the
who the waiver favored by identifying if
it was the plaintiff or defendant
so i think that kind of clears the way
and so you see the new amendment number
correct
all right
representative belanger make a motion to
are you voting on the amendment
oh yeah we have to vote on the amendment
first sorry
so he moved his amendment
and moved them in yeah so now we just
vote on it
okay voting on the amendment
representative desimone
yes
representative yo keller
absent at the moment
representative nelson
yes representative belanger
yes representative plutt yes
representative bean
representative smith yes representative
long yes representative nutting wong yes
representative grossman
yes representative levesque yes
representative tolorsky yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk is voting yes representative
altschuler
yes madam
chair rice yes
motion carries 14 to none
okay now
so i'm cody oh my gosh cody i clearly am
thinking about josh i apologize
representative belanger thank you madam
chair i moved otpa
okay voting on ought to pass as amended
representative disimone yes
representative yo keller is absent at
the moment representative nelson yes
representative belanger yes
representative plett
representative bean yes representative
smith yes representative long yes
representative nutting wong yes
representative grossman
yes representative levesque yes
representative toloreski yes
representative petrino me the clerk
voting yes representative altsula
madam chair rice yes
okay
um
so representative belanger you will do
the um
the committee
report for that since you made the
oh i'm sorry i thought he said that yeah
without objection we'll place it on
consent
so that was 12.65 right yes
all right which one is okay i'm going to
do 1465 next so we can start
okay
so um
then we will move on to house bill 1465
representative long do you have a motion
i do thank you madam chair
i'll move uh
amendment
but don't we have to have a motion first
a move otp ought to pass on 1465.
and i'll second it
so we're gonna we didn't have this
amendment before so i just think it's
fair to let
to make sure representative long gets us
1465. i passed them i passed them out
earlier
so
okay
so um
now you can introduce your amendment and
if you want to speak to it
sure thank you madam chair i'll uh i'll
and if i could explain it yeah please do
so
so this uh uh details a little better
the
two issues one was we wanted to assure
that the appointed attorney
wasn't representing the
wasn't representing the um the juvenile
in other matters such as civil
civil case or or what have you
um however the attorney would be
interested in that case ought to be
there
um because it has something to do with
the juvenile and that'll that that was
the death that was the
uh one of the one of the uh issues that
came up during the hearing
and then the the other change is uh use
of a
statement or confession from them from a
minor
it articulates better the uh you know it
it articulates better where
there there can be an interrogation if
the child's arrested
feels compelled
to
either divulge information or
say a confession
uh it adds that a reasonable per a
reasonable person thinking that the cha
that the juvenile may have been in that
situation
uh then the attorney would have had to
have been present for that situation so
in the cases of an arrest the attorney's
there
because that attorney is appointed right
away however it's um
you know if they're if police are just
questioning the juvenile or whomever uh
you know uh principal in school or
whomever
it's questioning the juvenile
a reasonable person being them
thinks that the child may have been
wanted to get out of something so i'm
gonna tell you a lie i'm gonna give you
a confession or what have you
um so that that's what this amendment uh
those are the two effects that this
okay um further discussion
representative ocala
thank you uh for recognizing me
so as far as the um
i i definitely like this new language a
lot better as far as i was just thinking
about the situation let's say there is
um a kid is at school they're not free
to leave the school right and so they
could feel that they're not able to
leave and maybe there's um
you know
a police officer there that's
that's helping be the you know school
officer and the the kid confesses to the
police the to the to the um
uh teacher they're not working in
conjunction with
the um police trying to interrogate the
person and so that makes a lot more
sense that this
that the conjunction with law
enforcement language is in there and so
i'm i'm definitely a lot more um
satisfied with this this language thank
so
i think this i think that this
makes it much better and i think it
so
oh that's right we have to vote on the
amendment i'm sorry
voting on the amendment
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes representative
nelson yes representative belanger
yes okay
representative plett
representative bean yes representative
smith yes representative long
yes representative nutting wong yes
representative grossman yes
representative levesque yes
representative toloreski yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk voting yes representative altsula
madam chair rice
yes
the vote passes 15 to zero
okay
representative long i'll move uh take
about a chair i'll move uh otp
a
on uh house bill 1465.
now second that
representative yokela yes um i don't
have the original um
bill in front of me and um
it doesn't say replace the entire bill
so um
is are
is there only two sections of the
of the bill
and we just kept the enacting clause or
okay there is there is a three and a
four
yeah
um
so the amendment just
addresses
1a
which is um
on line 13 on the first page
of the original bill right and then uh
section two with the statement of
confession of a minor
21.
so
there was one thing i believe that
richard had brought up um
that that
night weekends and holidays are not
available
was that for
in the original bill in
roman numeral 3
lines 11-14
for
the court shall follow the procedures
under and if appointment is made
promptly notify the minor and appointed
counsel
does that mean
i'm concerned that they that meant that
they didn't have
the ability to appoint counsel
on
uh nights weekends or holidays
okay where was this do you uh
yeah because i i wrote it down and
highlighted
um section three
i write stuff down and highlight it like
i'm gonna remember it when it's
time for me to be here
i should know better by now
yeah so so it says that um upon receipt
of such petition
the court shall follow the procedure so
they wouldn't be able to file a petition
if it was saturday or
sunday
right and so they're not going to get it
would be your communication requirement
so they wouldn't get a
a lawyer until the
until
monday
until the petition was filed in court
which is closed saturday and sunday so
we're okay with that are we okay with
that
i mean they're not going to hold the
child right are they going to hold the
child in
detain them without attorney that
right because the the point of this bill
is that they can get an attorney as soon
as essentially they are
detained
essentially right
and where's putting them in jail and
still not getting them the attorney
because it's a weekend yeah that's what
that's yeah i don't i don't know if it's
i don't know if the intent is when
they're detained
it's when there's a petition filed
it is when there will be an
attorney appointed not
not when the child gets stopped for
throwing something out the window or
whatever
in his car it's when it's when a
petition is filed
right the the um
it only sorry that's okay go ahead and
then then you'll be next the um the
uh
the detained thing was only for the
confessions we were talking the um
the
when you're actually charged is when
you're supposed to get a lawyer
according to this bill
so thanks for the clarification
okay representative all chiller
thank thank you madam chair so um
if i'm understanding your question
representative yokola you're looking at
line 13
on page two under section three of the
original bill is that correct
yes okay so the um
rsc rsa referenced 169 b12
um it says and
upon receipt of such petition the court
shall follow the procedures under rsa
169 b12
and if the appointment is made properly
notify the minor and appointed counsel
and
b12 is the chapter on delinquent
children an appointment of counsel
semicolon waiver of counsel and so what
this
bill would be doing is saying that we're
not waving we're actually we're getting
child counsel
and um
this
um
rsa says absent a valid waiver which
this will negate
the court shall appoint council at the
time of arraignment
so
it doesn't say anything about you know
at the time of of judicial intervention
or complaint it's at arraignment all
right so
um that question of yours is answered
in the statute of reference beautiful
great
is there any further discussion
concerns
all right i'll ask the clerk to call the
role
representative yokela yes
representative nelson
representative belanger
not here to representative belanger
oh so everybody has to turn theirs off
for his to work if you're not using it
yes
here we go very good representative
plett
yes and i haven't been using this all
day
representative bean
representative smith yes
representative long yes representative
nutting wong
yes representative grossman yes
representative levesque yes
representative solareski yes
representative petrino the clerk that's
me voting yes representative altsula
and madam chair rice yes the vote is 15
to zero
and this cannot go on consent because it
does have a fiscal note
and it's in the affirmative
sure
because
should we call the clerk's office and
ask
[Laughter]
okay look at us go
all right
okay all right up next is
um
1346.
do you have an amendment
um
oh you did oh madam chair i have an
amendment too i'm sorry say that too
okay i i do i did not know you were also
doing that so mine is still not here so
well let's do yours and maybe maybe we
don't need it first we need a motion
uh to pass right yeah emotion not to
pass
we're on nope 1346 it's uh
study to family
commission to study the family court
system and you want to second it
representative belanger seconds it
well first but yeah but we have to have
a motion before we can introduce an
amendment so the amendment number is i
have to find it now
i would like to um motion that we adopt
amendment uh
and i passed it out earlier but there
may be some more on the
table okay
over there
yeah if anybody can't find one there
okay
so if i could speak to it yes please do
thank you so um
my issue with uh
the
original bill my my bill uh or this
amendment replaces the entire bill my
problem with the original bill is that
that there was some things that didn't
really even have to do with a court that
it was studying
and it just um
re-re-uh
did it with a little bit less
people
as far as the number of people that
would be on the commission um just
reducing
like the domestic violence one from two
people to one and also
say
removing the language that said stuff
about like or and it
or someone interested in the area
which was kind of just like we can just
appoint whoever we want right um
and then um so i gave some new
um examples of what the commission would
look into
those are on lines 26
to
line seven on the second page
and
so it would be
um the frequency of equal shared custody
um
kind of like the effects of
uh delayed enforcement
of the child support because we've
talked before about how
people are not enforcing the child
support orders and so how does that
affect the families and and negatively
affect them and um
and then also
potentially
the
the rules being waived and does that
cause appeals more often if if we have
testimony about that um
there is also a discussion about
the ability of children to speak to the
um
in their child custody cases
is that being allowed right now or
should it be allowed and
at what ages and maybe they don't
do it in open court but
in the in the
uh privacy of the chambers so that they
are not unduly influenced and is that
the proper procedure or you know better
understand because there was questions
about whether or not the the judge is
alone in there with the kid um
and is that um
the appropriate uh
venue
um
also
uh
just um gals um there was
some testimony that was brought to us
about gals favoring one parent or
another
um
and
how much time the actual gal is spending
with children
and then um
and then on line six and seven i just
said pretty much anything that the
commission finds would negatively in
fact
impact the outcome that the court does
that would negatively impact
uh outcomes for families so it kind of
also if someone comes and testifies
about something else that is an issue in
the family court system that we have the
opportunity to look into that and
propose a report on that so
um
i requested when i asked for this bill
to be drafted that that we would have
like four years for the commission to
work do its work because i'm not sure
that um everything would be able to be
done in one year but ols
did not
did not draft it that way so um
my
my belief is that we should really have
four years
and then if if it's producing good
results then obviously we can have a
bill to extend that and if not then um
but i would want to uh
just accept this and then i would
propose an amendment in the in the
senate to to do the additional years if
if the committee is amenable to that
so thank you the uh thank you for this
josh of representative yokela
the only thing
i have issue and concern with
is that
the a minimum of one hour shall be
allowed for public testimony this is
just going first of all i think it's bad
for these people to have to keep opening
these wounds
i think that we have agendas for
meetings that will be posted
and then if the if someone in the public
sees that this is something that has
affected them they can come
and offer input but to
like set a minimum time and
all of that
really concerns me because we're going
to hear the same stories over and over
and over again we know what's happening
right we
for the most part we've heard it for
years
but i just think that by doing this
i think is more um
it just really
concerns me i mean anyone all the
publics are all all the meetings are
always public right we can publish an
agenda
and i don't know if we can get if if the
commission would be allowed its own
email address
i i don't know how that's done i haven't
heard of that being done
from a for a commission to have their
own email address you know what i mean
so that that's my only problem with it
because nothing can stop the people from
coming in and us being able to ask them
questions you know they can send us
written testimony
sure go ahead
thank you um so obviously i use the
original bill as a template and the
original bill had like three hours
as and so i didn't think that was
reasonable but um i thought um
so i reduced it to one i'm not
it's not the end of the world for in my
position
to say like oh this is how um
um the committee needs to
be
you know
we need to have a five hour long
you know hearing or whatever but i my
concern i guess
might be that um if we didn't say you
know we're going to be meeting for an
hour at least so that you that you that
the people that attend would have enough
time to speak and not feel rushed and
you know if there's only one person that
is coming that they would have enough
time to be able to speak and not feel
like that's that's um you know uh
sometimes you know there's
um i know that i was um
testifying or
i guess i don't know what i was doing i
was i was presenting to a commission um
or
um
kind of a committee
oversight committee
and
the oversight committee
um had an agenda
and they had a time frame in their minds
that this
hearing was going to happen and um
there was people on the agenda that
waited for hours that got
um the the the um the chair just said
okay now we we wanted to end this around
noon so uh
yeah everyone on the agenda that haven't
got
got to today we're just gonna push it to
the next time kind of a thing and um i
was on the outside of that just kind of
hearing the audience and the there was a
person in the audience that said this
always happens to me because i and like
i'm always at the end of the agenda and
they always just push me to the next
meeting kind of a thing and so there is
um
in
i think there is some value in saying
like hey we're gonna be here for an hour
you have your opportunity to to um you
know speak and if not we're going to be
working on
this this issue for that hour and so
but so so the other part of that though
to me would be
it says a minimum of one hour so one
person because we know
how people tell their stories in here
could go on for one hour that's just one
person
i don't think i don't think that
um so this says allowed for public
testimony i don't think a per person is
right but what if i have
10 people that i want to speak
and it it says like i feel like this
doesn't leave the chair any
leeway to
say can we we really need to move this
along
you know what i mean like when time is
getting short
things like that i think i think that's
exactly what i was just trying to say is
that we shouldn't be trying to rush
people if they
if they're trying to uh
um explain
obviously if it's more than an hour then
the the chair is free to say whatever
but if there is people that are
that have come to testify and they're
trying to to say how the criminal
justice system and in the family court
has has harmed them and you know whether
the the chair is allowed five minutes a
person to speak um and they want to sh
uh
i don't think that would be prohibited
by this this it would it
but those
they would need to be able to do it at
least so you know if it was five minutes
per sp speech then at least you know 12
people should be able to
speak okay
representative long thank you madam
chair so i i agree with the
representative that
uh because i i serve on some commissions
where
the public is not asked to speak and i
serve on some where they will ask them
to speak uh however the the uh so
uh monthly publicly noticed hearings to
provide an opportunity for members of
the public to testify and you leave it
at that because sometimes you'll get
the same person every meeting telling
you the same thing
which the chair has authority saying you
know mr x
we absolutely understand we heard that
next month so is there something
different uh so they have that control
um
i like the idea that there's public
comment on some of these commissions
whether it's professional or personal so
i don't know if we're looking to just
like strike that sentence sentence in
that is that what you're thinking or i
mean and there's also emails that um
uh people normally email like uh
they email either the chair
of the committee right um so there's
always that avenue there already
um i mean i
i was looking at nine period after
testify
uh the doctor rest okay yeah right
because the chairman pretty much has
that authority to
yeah i think that's good because we
could be having a discussion and we know
that someone in the audience
has something to offer
regarding that subject matter we're
right there they can raise their hand
and you know we can talk to them but if
we set a specific out because you would
have to set a specific hour
right during the meeting because
otherwise you're going to be into
something else someone's going to come
in late and say but it says
right you know you would have to specify
the hour on the agenda
yeah so
yeah
what you're asking here is that every
hour there'll be public testimony for an
hour a minimum of an hour so every hour
that's well no every meeting yes an hour
of public testimony
and you'll get an hour of public
testimony sometimes right but it's the
same thing right you know yeah i don't i
i feel like that that uh amendment is or
that change is
warranted it's not
contrary to the purpose of the bill
right so right
and would you
i'm kind of interested in what um yeah
what representative all shiller has also
had had ideas on her amendments
because maybe they need to be joined if
thank you madam chair thank you
representative um
i want to i think
many of us here have sat on commissions
and um
this one is ambitious this one is very
very ambitious and
i i i 100 agree with you and i think
most of us agree that this is a
unnecessary
dive into the family court system that
is that people are struggling with
um
with regard to
how the chair of a commission
prescribing a specific amount of public
input
is actually um and you know three hours
is
a lot
a lot of public input and um prescribing
one hour i i understand the motivation
um
there also has to be some consideration
made for
this coterie of people that we are
asking to come together and do this work
um on top of because most of every one
of them either has a job in social
services in the family court system
in advocacy or serving here in the house
or in the senate um
and then we're asking them to spend what
could be anywhere from you know five to
and then on top of that having to write
this report i think that's a large ask
an uncompensated large ask
so
would it would there be an appetite in
this committee to amend
the public input
to be
you know
publicly noticed hearings
with an opportunity for members of the
public to testify
um
no
i
i think that
well go ahead okay
we learn a lot from about the problems
or the issues that people are having
from this from the public testimony and
so while i think that they would be able
to do some work on their own on this
issue because of their knowledge of the
issue
um
and their personal knowledge of the
issue i think that um
the additional perspectives of um not
only the public but other um
professionals in this age in this field
that have their own experiences
brought to bear on the subject that that
is being
is important that we
have some time in that meeting that they
can say hey
um i heard you guys talking but what
about this kind of a thing and not have
to
just hear
some the commission like try and solve
the solute the problem within themselves
and
um
not have the
you know depending on the will of the
chair have the opportunity to have that
um say either a suggestion or
um
concern brought to the
to the
to the uh commission so i i think that
we should leave
the opportunity for at least some public
set um speaking time
and and if i may add that i think it
would be really good for
two members from the house judiciary
committee to hear some of these stories
you know i mean because
it isn't just us right we've got the uh
the judiciary people a member from the
senate could be a member that's not
affiliated with
these bills i think the more people we
educate the better
you know what i mean i think it i think
it will help going forward
when um when you know these these bills
come up but i really think it's
important for members of the judiciary
to
hear some of these bills some of these
issues representative long
so thank you madam chair and and i mean
all too often i'll sit on a commission
where the chair
invites a professional
and you'll see rank and file people
sitting at the commission
shaking their head no when this
professional is speaking
uh i mean the bottom line is this bill
was brought to us by
the years of listening to people you
know the way we're like wow how do we
get our hands around this right you know
so
i you know and again i think the
chairman will be able to say you know
mr smith
we heard that last month do you have
something different
you know that that that can be
controlled and
all too often on these commissions
there's a there's a time frame yeah you
know the the you know the chairman's
like
oh it's one o'clock i gotta be in
somewhere at 2 30. you know so you know
bingo see you next month
this commission ought to know if it
passes this commission ought to know
that this is going to be a time
constraining a lot of homework
um you know a commitment
it's not show up and take a vote and go
home you know
it's going to be a commitment so i i do
like the part of um
uh
requiring a public comment
so i
i i hear you i i agree with you that
there
there is an absolute place for public
input and this is why we're even having
this discussion because
of public outcry
i'm just trying to find a way to balance
the charge of this commission that's so
devolve
into
like what representative rice was saying
a place where people are
are exercising their frustrations and
then there's not time to address and
write that report
i want to give people a place to
to speak like we do here
but at the
at a commission
they have
they have a direction and they have a
deadline and they have things they have
to accomplish and
um
maybe there's a a compromise for every
other month
that you know at least six of the
meetings will have
public input um i would i would even say
remove the word minimum
and just stick to the one hour
right
i don't i don't think i i think i agree
with representative long it's not
necessary to to because what if no one
shows up what if there are zero people
that want to testify do you have to sit
there for an hour and stare at the wall
well
according to this a minimum of one hour
you would be anyways right so why not
just i i like representative long's
suggestion of just
of just saying you know sometimes in in
my public hearings for budget committee
or zoning board we open the public
session there's literally no one talk no
one's sitting there and then we close it
again right yeah so that we opened it
and closed it as
um as part of the process and it's not a
minimum of an hour
um you know
or any time frame i i i definitely agree
with representative long's suggestion um
yes
period after testify online nine
there it is and delete the rest wait and
you're is this on your amendment or we
are back at the regular bill on page two
on your
amendment on my amendment
line nine nine period after testify
after that
right
um
when i was um
suggesting
um thoughts from from you i was more
talking about like as as a whole because
obviously this is a rewrite of the
entire thing so did you um
have any
other topics that were specifically
mentioned in your amendment that the
commission should look at or um or did
you
kind of do it similarly to me and
so in mine
if can i use your
your amendment as a reference for
um
a lion 11 just says house of
representatives yeah i think well i'm
sorry i'm trying to translate my i wrote
off of um representatives representative
gay's amendment
and if you have representative gay's
amendment her part c
she had put in line eight two domestic
violence counselors who have worked at
crisis centers
have experience in family courts no
crisis center policies etc etc and i
changed that to
two appointees from member agencies of
the new hampshire coalition against
domestic violence so i think that covers
because
there is um
domestic violence counselor is not a
thing like there's nobody has that title
so it's not you know i think
my version is on line 13 of my amendment
okay and it says one domestic violence
specialist with a minimum of three years
experience it wasn't
um
like a specific title right it's not
capitalized right so it's just a what's
a domestic violence specialist though
um
someone who has familiar
familiarity with current policies and
procedures of new hampshire crisis
center
and uh
and then they would be appointed by the
governor so he would
say this person is especially like meets
these qualifications and i think that
that is
i think i could trust the governor to
decide whether or not they're a
specialist on that so i would i would
suggest that um
we actually have
within new hampshire we have family
violence prevention specialists
um
so um they're called fvps it's a special
designation and every crisis center has
family violence prevention specialists
they're charged what they do is they
work
half of their
responsibilities are to the crisis
centers and then they also work with
dcyf so when families are identified
as having um domestic or sexual violence
um
that has
that is part of their case
a family violence prevention specialist
is brought in to help that family
navigate through the family court system
um so
while domestic violence and um sexual
violence advocates who work for the
crisis centers um
can
lend that kind of
expertise to this commission for the
type of work type of information we're
looking for we're looking for people who
have worked with families who actually
are in the court system and for us
in new hampshire those are the family
violence prevention specialists that's
their job
and so i would pro it would be my
preference to
name them specifically so that we have
um
we have those we have that expertise
which is what we're looking for is that
kind of expertise
and
um
and you know i pointed okay appointed by
that's fine it would be i would i would
also just have it you know
recommended by the new hampshire
coalition against domestic and sexual
violence because those member agencies
run the fvps program
uh representative de simone yeah thank
you
thank you for taking my question this
question is for both
um
representative yokela
and
i can't i i don't want to miss pronounce
your name ma'am paul chiller ultimate
representative altschiller
on line 13 of representative
keller's
amendment it says one
family violence specialist on domestic
violence one domestic violence
specialist i'm sorry if we were to
change the verbiage to one
family violence prevention specialist
which is what you're talking about
with a minimum of three years experience
who has familiarity blah blah blah would
that
facilitate
your
request
um
close
i
my only other objection is to the three
years experience
um because
if you're asking for someone who has
been a family violence prevention
specialist for three years
that might be a harder sell because the
family violence prevention specialists
often start
in order to move up into that space they
already start as advocates so they've
you know you need experience and the
education to be a family violence
prevention specialist and you know you
may have a lot to offer but you've only
been doing that particular role for a
year and a half where you've been spent
six years prior to that working
within that system
so if we were to just strike the three
years of experience i i would be would
that work yeah i would are you okay with
that one i don't think we need two do
you
yeah
yeah i i could yeah one is i could do
one that's
just that just leaves another one out
there to be exactly to be doing the work
this is gonna be a tough sell to begin
with so
yeah
yes thank you um i
uh
i
so
kind of what what i'm gleaning from what
you're saying is the family violence
prevention specialist
there are some qualifications of being
having that title which
um
means that they're going to have some
experience with this
situation i think the
the um familiarity that the the
commission will benefit from
just by
already having that title and so the
additional
three years of experience having that
title is not necessary and so
i
have no
disagreement with that
so okay so i'm fine with that can we um
can we
with a minimum of three years experience
and just go a specialist who has
familiarity violence prevention
specialist
and so on line 14
familiarity with current policies and
procedures
and so of new hampshire crisis center so
i don't know can i yeah could i just i i
in my thing i just said um added an a in
fro in front of uh
procedures so a
current policy and procedure of a new
hampshire crisis center
um i would prefer it say a member agency
of the new hampshire coalition
member
agency
of what
of the new hampshire coalition against
domestic and sexual violence nakadzi
so that's our statewide coalition
new hampshire
coalition coalition
against against
domestic
and
sexual
violence
you got this
okay
i think i got great so there's 12 member
agencies so
within the 12 they'll be able to find a
person who has the
time and capacity to be able to
participate
so are you suggesting that they um
who has familiarity with the policies
and procedures of a member agency or is
just a member of that those one of those
agencies personally i think who has
familiarity with current policies and
procedures is redundant because if they
are a family violence prevention
specialist that's what they do they
don't have other jobs that's that's
their only charge
so who is a member
yes
of
a member agency
bye
okay
beautiful is that was that what kind of
the and we're agreed on one
yep yeah wonderful i think one is
enough
yeah and did you have others
different than
yeah i had one other one is um under on
your line 20 20g
an attorney who is also a member of the
dove project
in in my amendment i had said who is
currently or has participated in
um because dove project members com
sometimes they cycle in yeah to paste
because they're a volunteer
if they have a heavy case load at their
firm or within their own practice they
may bow out of dove for you know 12
months and then they come back in
so there's a lot of
dove attorneys who aren't necessarily
holding a case in the dove project but
could definitely speak to this
i like it current yeah an attorney who
is currently or has been a member of the
yeah
okay
great
um the
the last one was the um mental health
professionals
and i see that you um
you knocked them out right they just
eliminated it you just eliminated it
okay i thought that that was
that was a lot to find for people like
in new hampshire when we're like the two
can take that kind of time people need
to be doing their jobs
i thought that was added in there for
some of the other things that she had
which didn't really have to do with
courts but right i also i also took that
out so okay
yeah we're in agreement on that one
this is amazing
[Laughter]
all right so last thing did we we went
over the very end of your amendment on
the effective date
that the commission's uh report would be
due by november 1st of 2024
because it starts november 1st of 2023
24. and um so currently the bill says
ending 2024 is does everyone have a
super big um
um because it gets repealed in 2023 in
my current bill and i wanted to change
that to four years so 2026 is is that
now
it's part of this amendment right
wait why why are you why four
say we go to
and if we feel it's a need then the
chair of that
commission could come
to one of us to put in a bill to extend
it
i i just think we'll have a hard time
getting people to commit to four
um not only that but if someone you know
who was on it for the first two years
then isn't reelected it's almost like
starting over again with a new person do
you know what i'm saying
so i'd like to go the two and then we
um
my concern is that we would just have
another bill like you know if we just
keep on extending it for two years we
just have a bill every single session
added for two years if if they're doing
good work you know after two years i'm
you know if if you think that's going to
be
be fine
i'm not opposed to it it's up to the
committee i just yeah two years i just
think that that um
because it
it's a lot after two years people can
get very burnt out on this this is very
emotional
i go home and am a mess at night you
know what i mean like
because because i lived it i feel that
ptsd come back to me all the time
so for someone to have to do that for
four years
is just
i feel it's really hard
i
i don't believe that
if that they need to be there that the
same person needs to be there for four
years if they if they feel
that it's overwhelming then
they should be able to step down and the
you know the person appointing them
could appoint a new person right but i
just think let's do the two years and
then if we feel that there's more
we can we can you know
and we can stay on top of this
do we have them sent they should send a
report to us too
is the report is your recommendation
that there be a report after each year
representative or at the end of the
commission
i am just a vessel for this this
committee so what um i am fine with the
commit uh report every year um
i think that it would be helpful if it
was in um
um before you know filing deadline time
right so that we could
address some of those issues that were
brought before us
um
so i would maybe do the first report six
months
from the start
get a first report because then we'll
have a filing period right if i'm if i'm
thinking correctly
it starts november 1st
no this would start
once enacted so it could be as early as
june of this year and then it gets
repealed in november of the 24th right
so the first part so on line 26 the
remainder of this bill should be
effective upon passage so this
commission can be start to be built
right away as soon as the bill is signed
and then
it's just whether or not we um repeat
like when we end the commission right
now first report
six months
i think because you figure what by july
this will be signed june or july right
right so that would mean january so so
it'll take a month to put the commission
together so their first meeting like
realistically on an accelerated schedule
the first meeting
would be september and that would be
organizational there will not be like
the first that's ambitious within 45
days what about seven yeah
months
what about seven months the fir for the
first report
okay so we see what direction they're
going in
right
that way we can we can see the direction
they're going in
and say
is this really what we had in mind or
whatever i don't know but if they have
some concerns we have time to draft
bills we have times to attach stuff to
amendments to bills you know what i mean
so i think seven months representative
belanger uh thank you madam chair and uh
what so
if if the plan is to have the commission
go for two years
and then you can readdress the problem
of it
close ending closing however you want to
phrase it
what if
instead
and i don't know because i know we can't
bind future
legislatures
but
in
the
bill it states
that
an automatic extension
requested by the chair
for additional two years i can do that
unilaterally it has to it has to come
from everyone
the chair doesn't have that doesn't it
doesn't have all no no
not you requested by the chair of the
commission to the children and family
law committee that it would no i think
it still has to be i think it's still
happening because i just i see an issue
with
let's just
you know we need to extend this
commission two more years and then it
so i could for you know unfortunately i
could foresee that being an issue so
to avoid
that there
may be being a safeguard if you will
representative long thank you so so it's
45 days they have to effective uh the
first meeting so if it's july august
september you're looking at october
november is not ready for a you know if
you want to submit a notification so
what i would do for two years
then the effect of
the uh the report is due on november 1st
and november 1st 24.
and that's the two years okay
right
okay
and and then leave it leave it at that
i mean it gets repealed
after 24 unless
the report in 23
gives somebody a heads up that we may
want to extend this well yeah it would
be a sunset just like you know because
for instance right now
we're going to be talking about some
legislation coming up that is sun
setting two other commissions that have
run their course and there has been we
already did that oh i missed it before i
walked in yes i'm sorry but so what you
talked about while i was
while i was on the highway having a
conversation about my speeding
[Laughter]
we appreciate your enthusiasticness to
get here yes yes i did explain where i
was going and why
and uh
so nonetheless
um so what similar to that
this legislative body commission
began two commissions that were that
were to address specific problems and
they did that
and now there has been we have
identified new problems so we have a new
commission that is going to fold those
others in
so what we cannot predict is if in two
years this commission
maybe it keeps going or maybe it goes
into another commission or another i
think we need to leave an out for it to
either complete its work
or
if it's going gangbusters
then
it will it will be it will be asked to
be renewed
so
i think we have to trust the next
legislature to
evaluate the efficacy of the work that
we put in place
so we'll report november 123 and
november 124 yeah and leave it at that
all right so we will have
is that the
was that the
[Laughter]
do you want to run down there instead of
emailing it will that be quicker for you
explaining it in person
yeah
okay do we want to recess for an hour
and have lunch or do this last one and
how many more do you have just two this
one and the one that's being amended
okay
i didn't expect it to go on so long
we are such communicators in this room i
love it
all right so you run down and do that or
do you want me to wait i don't know what
you want me to do
i think that a lunch would be
appropriate i know but i have people
that have to leave
i mean couldn't you just have a
different
self
no
i consist out i'll recess this one and
we're all going to agree on this
amendment right so i we don't need these
subs here so
whoever would have to leave can leave
us
so let's do
1647.
josh you had
a motion out to pat
okay secondly bye
uh second
representative de simone
now i just have to find that darn
amendment
1647.
oh five six six is the amendment
0566h
okay
would you like to speak to your
amendment
no i talked about it at the hearing so
um
uh oh no i didn't talk about it at the
hearing because there was uh
uh an additional amendment that i gave
you guys after after the hearing which
um
addressed
the um issues from the judiciary
about
um did i not
i have it right here
i have it
0566 do you want to look at mine
yep
um
do we have another one after this no
just that one this one and then okay
this one and then the one that he's
yeah yeah it was um i walked around to
you guys and yeah
you did yeah
1647 i think this is
yep
wrong
so
um so as i as i explained
yesterday
i think that this um clarifies more the
language um as far as
making it simpler for people to be able
to understand and follow especially when
you um combine this with the um
the worksheet that i handed out so that
you could see kind of how that math
follows through
um
with each of those definitions
and um so i
hope
found it
yep
h
did you have anything else to add or no
no unless there is any questions or does
anyone have any questions for
representative
yokela or any questions regarding the
amendment
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
on the amendment
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes representative
nelson
yes representative belanger yes
representative plett yes representative
bean
representative smith yes representative
long yes representative nutting wong yes
representative grossman yes
representative levesque yes
representative toloreski yes
representative petrino that's me the
clerk is voting yes representative
altula
and madam chair rice yes
the voters 15 to
zero okay
so do you would you like to move out to
pass as amended yes okay now second
okay
representative
thank him uh i mean i i agree that the
amendment clarifies
better
uh however i just think we're
i just think we're all over the place
when it comes to a calculation of this
child support
and
i i'm not sure i i know for me i'm not
i'm not ready to uh approve this because
i think there's unintended consequences
down the road with the courts on
disagreements
um
i respect the attempts representative
uh but i'm going to be opposed
to the otpa
all right seeing none
right
representative of desimone yes
representative yokela yes
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes representative plett yes
representative bean
representative smith yes representative
long no representative nutting wong no
representative grossman no
representative levesque no
representative zolowski no
representative petrino that's me the
clerk will be voting no representative
altula
and madam chair yes
and madam chair votes yes
there won't be a minority there won't be
there will okay everybody heard that
there will not be a minority report yeah
the vote is eight to seven just want to
make sure did everybody have to hear
that
they did because i just wanted to make
sure because last year i guess minority
reports disappeared i didn't know and i
i just want to have clarification yeah
what was the vote eight to seven
years so i guess you don't want that to
i thought maybe i could sway seven
people
i'm kidding
all right
so now i guess we will break for lunch i
understand some of you have to go home
but while we're waiting for
representative yokela's amendment
right
yeah yeah so and we're all in agreement
on that one so
thank you so much for being here i
oh god no i'm not dealing with that
today
you
all right so
i'm going to
um the exec session for house bill
and representative yokela
hi i would like to withdraw my previous
amendment and uh propose amendment
uh
2022-0625-h
to be adopted by this committee
would you like to speak to that
do i need a second
second
uh sure uh
so this is an amendment that i believe
um
addresses all of our discussion earlier
this
um
morning and
um looks to be
ready for
all right
oh we have to vote on the amendment god
i always forget that part
all right the clerk's ready he'll call
the roll all right voting on the
amendment
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes
representative
nelson yes okay
representative belanger
absent at the moment
representative plett absent
representative bean yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes
representative
nutting wong not here representative
grossman yes
representative levesque is absent
representative toleski is absent
representative petrino the chair excuse
me the clerk
[Laughter]
yes
madam chair rice
amended and i'll second that
okay
okay and now the motion is ought to pass
as amended oh are you ready oh my gosh
he's ready
okay so the clerk can call the roll
uh to pass as amendment
representative desimone
yes representative yokela
yes
representative
nelson yes
belanger
absent representative plett
absent representative bean yes
representative smith yes
representative long yes
representative nutting wong is absent
representative grossman yes
representative levesque is absent
representative talarsky is absent
representative petrino the clerk that's
me here
and representative altschuler
yes and
madam chair
right yes
very good okay
one one question what's the matter he um
he voted here instead of yay or nay and
that that was
we were just chuckling about that thing
oh okay um it's okay at least i didn't
call myself that was 13 46
right so where's the rest of my papers
there's that why am i missing too
um
hold on bear with me i'm trying to find
did we do 16
47 yet we did okay i just watched i
no
my flow chart looks like this see i'm
missing two pages
oh my
i had him earlier
oh for the love of pete okay well we're
good anyways um so everyone that so you
have to do the committee report for
bill number josh yep 1346
um
does everyone have that will go on and
consent
oh yes without objection we'll put it on
consent thank you sorry
um i just want to make sure that we have
so
representative long you have a committee
report right
okay
so
one
two i just i'm counting to make sure i
didn't miss any
you